nice to see you
good to see you too i just saw you you
know
well i mean and i'm now we're seeing you
again yes it's like we're just yeah
we're just doing this
um
it's hard i think to resist the idea of
like your character now being in the mcu
and like what that means
for
you know for katie's life and where she
could go if you could write this
spin-off film or the spin-off series
that stars her what is it about
um i can't tell if it would be you know
another movie like this or just kind of
like uh one of those home renovation
shows because she wants to become an
interior decorator
nice yeah and like shaun she would he'd
do all like the knocking down of the
walls he can knock down the walls i mean
he could tile if he wants
whatever people like to do that
people enjoy doing that they like a
little accent wall painting he can do
whatever he wants pretty much it's it's
a free world in in my interior design
um world
one of my favorite things that you guys
do in this movie and again one of the
most relatable things is just going to
karaoke yeah singing your hearts out and
having a great time
if you were to have a bender and have a
karaoke partner to go on that vendor
with that's an avenger or someone in the
mcu
who would it be
well if i if i couldn't say obviously
shanxi i would
i would say
wong or groot
because i feel like groot would would
just say this
but would keep the melody do you think
that he would keep a melody
[Laughter]
what would be the perfect song that you
and groot are singing bohemian rhapsody
no no it wouldn't be
i love how you're trying to figure out
the mechanics it's great i love you it
would be the best that's well then there
you go that's the show yes spin-off show
it's just that
it's just us doing bohemian rhapsody for
45 minutes every day
it'll come out every day
yeah
um i asked florian because his his
family on instagram is big nasty what
his nicknames for you and steven would
be said for sema's charming dragon for
you would be expect the unexpected as
your nickname do you think that is
a fair nickname for yourself
so what would would people call me like
etu
like is that my name
um because
yeah i like x i would do a cool thing
where i would drop the ease
right and i just do expect the
unexpected
second 90s like a 90s uh r b group
exactly it'll be great
that's perfect yeah and again with groot
with a groot in it all sort of
yes
okay hey thanks again for uh for doing
this once again good to see you yeah
nice to see you cool